but uh yeah you guys got to go to my
home country yeah last time we went to
Thailand we just came back from Thailand
didn't really post much about it
um just kind of went there I kind of
like invited you guys at very very last
minute to come yeah luckily you guys
were free
yesterday for like three days yeah I
think three days was the perfect amount
yeah really I wanted to be there a
little bit longer I mean
I because we because we only really got
to explore like kind of like I feel what
is kind of like a corner of Bangkok with
the super touristy stuff we did yeah
which is fine because it's like that's
how you get introduced to it of course
it's through the touristy stuff yeah I
don't know taking more than three days
off of work oh my God
yeah bro you literally cycle for eight
days what are you talking about yeah I
know but that was work though
if he's not if he's not filming it all
right well technically I filmed the Vlog
so I didn't yeah all right
I don't know what your excuses yeah no
but it was great um yeah I feel like no
I I kind of agree like we did kind of go
to all the touristy places but I think
that just made me want to stay for a
little bit longer I think like next time
if we were to go I definitely want to
maybe I mean I don't know what's
anything else
I kind of like took you to like let's
say the more pristine clean areas uh
next time you're in Thailand we'd love
to take you to some of them all like
back ends let's say like dirtier places
yeah because you can get a lot of
interesting things there
um do you guys have like a lot of like
islands and stuff like that oh yeah
a lot of the big tourist destinations
are they're like really pretty Islands
yeah yeah that's I think that's what I
want to do now yeah yeah sure yeah me
too yeah I'll join you on that one yeah
hell yeah I I it was an interesting
experience from like the moment we got
off the plane it felt very different
this is the first time I've gone to a
country in a while where uh I wasn't
able to speak the language the language
remotely so yeah you know because we've
been doing America and Japan which is
like okay I know how to talk in Japan
yeah yeah so it was kind of weird going
to a place and being like that guy again
who couldn't he literally was like
please speak English please I felt bad
but it was what it was but like you get
off the plane and immediately I think
American uh immigration has ruined
immigration for me which is I was
terrified right I was conditioned by
America to be terrified and when we get
to the passport gate they literally just
look at the passport for like one thing
like get in yeah go go get inside with
you yeah in Thailand because like so
much of our economy is tourism I'm just
like that dude I don't even like did
they even ask me
no question the dude didn't even talk to
me he
silently grabbed my passport looked at
it looked at my face stamped
yeah dude they were doing like a paper
please speedrun like I I wanted to like
I was like damn I should just say I'm
working let's see what happens
this [__] felt too easy America I gotta
ask questions just go to the toilet
was the line long when you were when you
got it no it was super it was super
quiet and uh then then the question was
like oh [__] it's not America I can't
like Uber or I can't do anything right
it's like [__] I don't have any money I
don't have anything
taxi yeah yeah so we were like [__] what
do I do with the cabs and I also don't
have a SIM card I don't have anything so
I went over to the SIM card right it was
like three of them they all look really
sketchy I'm not gonna lie yeah and uh I
I'm like can I have two SIM cards please
it was like 10 bucks each yeah and like
yeah sure could have your passport and
then they would all whip out their
iPhones and start taking pictures of my
passport I'm like wait what is what are
you what is this what are you guys this
is my Personal Collection why are you
all ripping out iPhones what is this I I
was really confused I was like what
what's the were you guys taking pictures
for they're like oh we just have to do
this I'm like oh you're just hot you
know I don't know
weird and then I was like okay okay and
I was like can I pay my car they're like
cash only I'm like that's weird
um we're in an airport okay it's fine
it's fine I'll get some cash and then
come back give it to them yeah and then
I I'm like all right got my SIM cards
go to get the taxi and I'm pretty sure
I'm getting ripped off right away yeah
okay because I I'm it's like they they
want to charge me uh something like 60
bucks like USD right I know from from
what I've heard from Thailand that's
that's in Thailand that's extortion yeah
it is and I was like but will the taxi
be there right away and will will it be
a big taxi because there's like there's
like a group of us and they were like
yes I was like scan me take my money yo
bro you paid 60 bucks for a taxi in
Thailand yeah I think it was like 48 USD
which is 100 ripoff but dude we
literally rocked out right away and it
was all ready to go yeah I think there's
no question because when I heard that
from Connor right again this is America
corrupting my mind I was like oh
see bucks for like what is it like a 40
minute like taxi ride I'm like all right
yeah that's fine it was a big van it was
like a big van that could you know
obviously fit all of us yeah um but so
you know in my head I was like okay yeah
I mean that's not too bad but then the
second time we got onto the taxi and the
guy put the meat put the meter on yeah
and I saw 30 Baht was the starting price
I'm like it's like 80 cents yeah it was
like a 30 minute cab ride was like 10
bucks I was like what the [__] not even
it was like it was insane yeah it sounds
like Japan could never yeah I mean like
first rule when you come if you ever
come to Thailand and pretty much every
Southeast Asian country
um if you get a taxi meter only like
yeah if you really really need to they
will try to like get a fixed price yeah
I noticed this yeah you're trying to do
that I get it I look white as [__] you
should scam me yeah like he would I was
like Hey I'm going here and he just said
something I didn't get it I was like
he's like three or something guys
I realized afterwards who's asking for
like five times the price up front and
then I think like at one point we split
up into two taxis Joey went and then I
went yeah we all went the same direction
and I told him I wanted I wanted the
meter until he paid the 300. I think it
came like a hundred or something yeah so
I picked a third of what Joey paid so to
be fair that 300 Baht uh taxi ride I
remember because we were heading to uh
the big markets I forgot what the name
of it was
um yeah that one right um so we were
heading there
um and I told the guy that you know we
were heading there and this guy clearly
was very excited right right that it was
like oh he's taking a tourist right yeah
so he was trying the entire 30 minute
taxi ride this guy was trying so hard to
sell me on this Market that we were
heading but the only thing he could say
was 14 Market 14 market
and he would just repeat that 30 minutes
and I'm like yeah I get a borrow this 14
of them I get it and then every time I
would respond he's just laughing
Thailand happy happy
and I was like I'm like yeah you see you
seem very happy about it yeah but uh
yeah no it was like I think that's like
one thing about like that I guess uh if
you can call it the Southeast Asian like
living experience right it's like
everyone's just so chill and it's just
like so happy that you're there that
like because you know you very rarely
get anything like that in Japan right
like maybe in Okinawa right you would
get someone that talkative and that like
people are trying to express people
yeah yeah that that's that's one of the
big reasons why I moved out of Thailand
after living there for like three four
years yeah nothing done
I noticed as well dude people just don't
indicate ever
suggestions yeah they seem like a
pointless thing this dude we were only
an hour ride didn't touch his [__]
indicators once
they would either not touch the
indicator or when say they wanted to
Signal going into the left lane yeah
they would flick the indicator on for
literally the mood when you're driving
into Ireland it's just like who's gonna
stop me who's gonna stop me because
because literally you just have to like
go yeah everyone was just being a dick I
swear it makes traffic slower because
everyone's being selfish yeah and it's
just slowing everything down the moment
the taxi just starts driving off I can
just see the objectives survive
it's so scary to be in the front it's
like you are getting tantalizingly close
to these like especially the bikes as
well oh my God I mean like I knew
southeast Asia had a lot of bikes right
because you know I've been to the
Philippines yeah but like Jesus Christ
these bikes are [__] speed demoning
through these like trucks and all these
taxis you know avoiding the lanes and
stuff like that I'm like how does how do
you how does anyone survive uh I mean
like it's just like it like I said in
Thailand and mostly Southeast Asian
countries you just need Ultra instincts
he's like to like survive right because
there's like you are constantly just
checking every mirror possible because
it's not the cards you need to worry
about it's the motorcycle oh yeah okay I
don't you know what I don't in in the in
the uh environment of driving in
Thailand I don't care if a car doesn't
indicate that's just normal right you
know
um but if you're changing a lane there
is you you always have this Instinct
that there is going to be a motorcycle
driving pass or a motorcycle doing
something bro some of these taxi drivers
have like the periphery of a deer like
they just like they can see behind
without looking back it's like yeah I
can see I can sense two bicycles
like holy [__] if you're driving on a
motorbike my God you're just praying
that people aren't being dicks yeah
exactly and honestly like it's
Thailand's one of those like Michael's
one of those cities where you risk
people risk their lives daily going on
motorcycles me included uh because the
traffic's so bad yes right and uh
there's some sometimes there's just no
system in place place right now
bangkok's still very much a developing
City especially with this public
transport that sometimes uh you choose
getting stuck in a traffic jam for two
hours or it's a 20 minute taxi ride
which one are you gonna take and you're
like well I'm risking my life but that
20 minute taxi right that that 20 minute
motorcycle ride looks damn appealing
right now man ain't gonna lie
um but yeah did you guys go on like the
tuk-tuks as well yeah
that was interesting because again like
it was like a five minute ride and the
dude was like 300. I was like I was like
dude I'm like yeah this this looks like
it weighs 10 pounds there's no way the
guess the gas usage in a year is
probably not even 10 bucks what are you
talking about I saw I remember the first
time we wrote the talk talks at night
like Connor did like a full one gamer
move and the guy was like 300 but
obviously you know we couldn't all fit
into one talktalk yeah can only see
maybe like what three people at most
yeah so we had to get two talks and
Conor did like a big burn remember where
he's like all right let's do a package
deal yeah 500 for two well originally I
was like 200 and even then I know 200 is
too much stuff yeah I'm like hey you can
scam me but just give me this I just
want to bother yeah I just want to feel
like I belong here yeah yeah yeah I
bought it with him yeah obviously I knew
I was getting ripped off yeah I was like
200 and he was like no uh 250. I was
like 250 for both and he's like all
right sure then he shouted the dude who
had no affiliation to him behind him
being like we're taking them both for
250 yeah he's like I didn't know what
the guy said but I could make it out
pretty much he said follow me and make
it 250.
so you didn't tell them where we were
going to follow me and holy [__] these
things felt dangerous dude oh they are
yeah no seat belts you're holding on for
dear life the dude's going like 60 miles
an hour and you're like holy [__] this
is cool but oh my God I'm gonna die I
don't know if you saw but like before we
went on to those two talks there was
like a group of about six people in
front of us right and I thought we had
to wait a little bit right because I saw
like you know oh while we were driving
on the road these talks could you know
maybe fit two people on average right
maybe three if you squeezed in but there
was a group of about six of them they
all got into one tuk-tuk and they're
just like he literally cramped in this
tiny little thing and they're like oh
yeah a hotel please and I'm like bro
no way
sometimes it is extremely tightly packed
and I was like that I mean it's
dangerous already yeah and that felt
like why not why not add more risk yeah
because I've seen like entire families
get on these like motorcycles you know
like yeah they put like their two
children at the front and the the
parents are sitting on and then on top
of that they have their shopping on
their like motorcycles they are packing
these things up to the brim I I it's
just it just I think what blew my mind
for one was just not only the sheer
amount of motorcycles that are on the
road but also just like how casual
people are driving these things through
that environment like I Remember by Soul
you know usually when you're on the back
of a motorcycle right yeah the first
thing is like you know make sure you're
sitting in front you know holding onto
the driver right maybe maybe wearing a
helmet if you want to be extra careful
yeah I remember wearing a helmet no
first of all no one was wearing a helmet
second of all I remember I saw this
woman who was sitting to the side not
holding on to anything just looking at a
phone what the [__] I mean this
motorcycle's just it's just sitting
there like yep all right tell me when
tell me when we were here like you know
like Jason Bourne like really like Chads
in the movies when you see the stunts
you sing on a motorcycle yeah
that's a nice ride yeah that's that's a
pretty good A whole motorcycle to
yourself yeah that's actually a pretty
normal way for women to sit on the
motorcycles because a lot of times if
they're wearing skirts right like uh you
know they want to they want to sit kind
of like that because it looks a bit more
elegant and they don't need to like but
like at least you know like if I if I
had to sit like that I would at least
like hold on to something this one was
just free hand one hand on the phone
she was waiting for a doctor like you
know it was just the most casual like
yep all right uh I know my life's in
danger right now but I really gotta
check Twitter
I just there's this bang it's weird I
have to retweet this right now yeah I
mean like it's it's definitely like no
matter how much I have described it in
the past there's nothing that I can like
replicate the feeling of just the
insanity of Southeast Asian roads and
just how the rules work over there
um it's it's a free-frow and it's always
been a free-frow and and kind of like
every taxi you go to especially
especially if you're gonna if you're a
foreigner they're gonna try to barter
with you and they're trying you're gonna
try and get the best price possible oh
yeah dude everyone you've got us that
taxi dude it was like at the moment they
saw us wanting a cab like yeah 20 dude
spawned they were all shouting yeah
was like I don't know who you were
talking to I think you were talking to
the crowd and you were just like no no
no it was weird it was just like God was
like I want a taxi yeah yeah it wasn't
until a lot later maybe because I was
drunk but it wasn't until a lot later I
realized that they were all taxi drivers
I thought I thought we were just getting
jumped by like 20 dudes I was like God
you're okay and I was like oh they're
all taxi drivers yeah because like what
happens is obviously uh I took the um I
took them to a place called Asia teak
which is which is like a really nice
bougie place right by the river uh in
Bangkok uh but they needed to go home uh
to the hotel and so I know how it works
you go over they see a group of tourists
and like a group like a group of NPCs
basically well just four it was good and
and uh one of them comes up and goes
like Oh 300 Baht and I'm like
if you are willing to speak yeah I'm
like I am not a Taurus I I will not even
attempt to like take this number can
anyone say give me a better number and
as soon as I as soon as I just ignored
the guy two other dudes would be like
well we'll do it for half the price and
I remember I remember like uh turning
back to Conor and I'm and I'm like is
this price I gave for you and Connor's
like go go a bit lower go a bit and so
I'm like I'm like okay I'm like we
wanted to see if he could bother them
yeah I was like I want to see how good
this modern is right yeah yeah and so uh
Conor's like get it low and I was like
actually I did not mean even she passed
by the way no no no no no you just don't
want to be ripped off because 90 of the
time I didn't want to have to deal with
change anyway I was like just [__]
just kidding okay so so there's one of
this yeah
I was I was curious for me yeah
sometimes you seem like I'm like no I
will not pay five bucks for a taxi no
because uh like the thing is no matter
what price if if you agree on a price
basically if you could agree on a fixed
price it's always going to be higher
than the metered price no matter what
otherwise
it was like a 10 no not even ten like a
seven minute Journey it would have been
like 50 on the meter yeah exactly so no
matter what you agree to so it's kind of
like the price you agree to to just have
the convenience of of of just being like
I can't be asked to deal with this
[__] let's just like agree for a
price just yeah it's basically payable
so yeah
Connor I I kind of did them a bit dirty
a little bit because I'm like bro come
on I'm tired man come on dude do me a
favor do me a favor man like you know
you could you can go a little bit lower
because uh in Thailand and I'm sure most
other Southeast Asian countries if
you're uh speaking that language and if
you're off their nationality then
they're gonna they're gonna do it a
little bit low so I'm like do for your
bro man do you for a brother and he's
like all right two taxis just for you
for that price that you want I'm like
cool and I'm like all right boys get in
the taxis and I'm like like pushing them
to get in the taxis and then uh everyone
gets in the taxi me and Senior are
staying in another place because we're
going back home and he's like are you
not getting in I'm like no just take my
friends
I'm like like you yeah boys
yeah but that's that's yeah that's kind
of like especially especially like the
tourist culture in Thailand you know
there's there's no 50 as well there's no
50 note 20 note oh there there is
there's a 52.
you can't see this once really yeah I
did not have any these are mythical
things I never saw oh dude I I I've
collected those like Pokemon cards I
have all them because every time the the
ride was we agreed on like 150 yeah I
was like what I can't ask him for 50
change after I just bottomed him down I
feel kind of cheeky you know what I mean
really so I I would just like just just
keep the 200. it's fine I don't know I
was like
I know you're already ripping me off I
think we bought uh at one point as well
that we bought the most expensive Pad
Thai oh really oh yeah we got scammed
100 I don't know if you if I told you I
paid this month for a pad thai I think
you'd kill me how much I don't think I
paid for Pad Thai yeah
it was it was it was four probably you
know like maybe that big I didn't know
how big the pets was a family size I
didn't know how much the pad thai was
until after I bought it and I was like
excuse me 150.
very cute guys I paid we paid 750 for a
pet shop
s
that's about 20 that's a bit more than
20 bucks yeah that's like 20 25 bucks oh
yeah I'm losing my [__] Pad Thai not
here
oh my God
I knew when we paid it I the only thing
I felt bad about is like God's gonna be
so ashamed yeah I didn't mind because I
was like hey I don't mind getting
scammed a little bit Yeah the food was
good it was great it was good Pad Thai
to be fair I mean all of it was good
yeah I don't think I had a bad maybe
you'd thought it was bad pad thai too
all right I mean Pad Thai is like pretty
hard to uh [__] up because uh pad thai
is the like I guess it's like the most
kind of like uh common dish especially
when tourist comes in that they want to
try uh when I was like trying to show
you around I was trying to find a store
and a store that actually did some of
the noodles that I liked but every store
was like no we only do Pad Thai here and
I'm like okay we're gonna touristy area
uh I wanted to show you guys some other
like more spicier maybe less no noodle
dishes
um especially like Drunken Noodles for
for some reason well I'll try that yeah
unfortunately uh Drunken Noodles are
normally so uh sold where there's a lot
of like dirty bars and stuff like that
which we didn't go to that time but uh
next hopefully next time